[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are exploring the question
how do we deal with YouTube burning
youtubers burning out is something that
for what you can say for four months has
been in the media it's been in the in
the media in the conversation not only
on YouTube but in articles about YouTube
that have articles in the media more
mainstream but one could easily make an
argument that it's been something that's
been a topic of discussion for years so
around here
yeah yeah around here too so we're gonna
throw our hat into the mix of the voices
that have already spoken about this can
we be burned out we're volunteering here
for for youtubers implosion just
throwing our voice into the mix so we
have a perspective on this we want to
talk a little bit about some of the
things that have been said I think this
even if you've you've read about this
even if you've seen the other people
talk about it we're gonna be talking
about our personal perspective on it how
we have dealt with burnout how we feel
about being burned out or not now
because I will say that I mean it is it
is an issue that is very close to us I
mean it is weird weird why are you
yawning yawning now you're already bored
you're burned out with this conversation
yeah I was setting a what I was doing it
don't make an audible noise I was
setting like a mental listeners won't
know that you a mental kyani when I'm
talk I'm do I did the yawn for the video
people man video people I mean I didn't
really need to yawn yeah I did it and I
did it for also for the audio P it's
like it I heard it's a setup it's a
setup it was intentional I was hoping
that you would John you wanted to when
you saw me didn't you you thought about
it but it's not a it's not a volunteer
oh man I wish I could yarn right now I
saw him yawning man that looks so
pleasurable contagious yawning I know
it's contagious but I didn't we
that I yeah but you wanted to really on
the inside what I was trying to say was
we have certainly dealt well I wouldn't
say dealt with it as if it's something
only in the past but there's been acute
moments of it and I think you know so I
think that and cute moments absolutely
yeah
so we'll get in all that I'm saying I'm
saying it it's gonna get a little juicy
this is not just this is not just an
academic exercise in conversing about
other people's burnout but it's deeply
personal to us and what what you know
for what it's worth we'll share our
experiences plural yeah with burnout and
I think it will be I think it could be
helpful to anyone who is self-employed I
mean I think it could be it could be
helpful to anyone period who could be
burned out in anything vocationally
mm-hmm or with anything but I I think it
will especially be helpful to those who
are content creators but also those who
are self-employed and kind of make your
own schedule and the traps that you can
fall into given that so we'll get into
all that but we did want to on a lighter
note first just I I I'm a verbal
processor so I need to verbally process
what happened to us at a party recently
because I think that there's there's
something I need help there's something
I need I just need to learn from it and
at this point I'm baffled and I feel
like I need more help than you because
you abandoned me and then this okay okay
well then I feel like at some point I
may need to apologize okay
directed so you know what I'm talking
about so I'll let you take the lead and
then you can yawn at me as a signal when
when you expect me to apologize okay so
how can I put this we do not typically
frequent Hollywood parties it isn't
something that we have made a part of
our lives but we are in this town to
for better or worse play the game a
little bit and there are other things
that we're trying to get off the ground
and other projects and ambitions that we
have that hopefully will become things
that you may or may not enjoy in the
future and one of the ways of that
happens is you got to play this you got
to play this PR game a little bit right
huh you got a be seen at certain places
you got to stand on red carpets and do
your prom pose with one leg in the air
so you you are who you're seen with I
think is what you may be reducing
Hollywood to yeah as a game but I will
also say practically speaking you know
you relationships Drive projects and and
in getting things going so a lot of it
yeah a lot of it is who you know you
know it's not about having the best idea
solely or having the root being right
for a part we're not actors but let's
say you are you know it's sometimes it
sadly it it comes down to who you know I
mean that's come an actor and those are
two different things so like being
having your picture taken with somebody
is it that feels nasty to me yeah what
but the thing that I'm okay with and and
you know what I'll do that I'll do a
little bit of that and see what happens
but I also trying to meet people who are
doing things that you could potentially
work together yeah that's not too dirty
right no no it's just part of life
but I will also see it happen at parties
a lot of times I will say that that's
not my only my motivation may be an
equal measure mm-hmm it's just to have a
good time I mean I like to go places you
know and I'm just curious
we took our we took our wives and we
invited to this party you know Hollywood
we anticipate that there's gonna be
people there that we might recognize
from television and film maybe even the
Internet it's just it's a fun atmosphere
so I don't want to sell it short I don't
want to say that oh this is drudgery and
I'm just going to build relationships
now I say
the initial motivation is from a PR
standpoint but then in the midst of it
I'm like well I'm gonna have a good time
you know I you don't get many nights out
when you when you've got children it
just doesn't happen right so because
that I mean the fact is we we're not
invited to Hollywood parties but then at
a certain point there is a there are
people who you can work with who get you
invited to parties I mean it sounds
again that sounds yeah but that's a
little odd right no that's just how the
industry but I didn't know that I was
just like oh there's parties know people
you're invited but there's like parties
there might be a party put on by a brand
and then they're like people come to
these people yeah and well it might I
say that there are people who might not
say it get you invited to a party get
you invited to a party yeah
but what I wasn't saying is we go into
these situation with a chip on our
shoulder I mean we talked about the chip
on our shoulder already I know those of
you who are our mythical beasts or like
guys I don't understand you guys do this
thing for this audience and yes you're
right and what we have is amazing but
there's still a lot of things that we
want to make and there are these there's
gatekeepers standing at the gates of
these gates that we want to go through
professionally create well let me say
creatively it's not just a professional
it's creatively yeah like a movie but
when we come into so when we go into
that party we kind of know that okay
well we're going to see people that we
know from things that we like to watch
but it's probably not it's not unlikely
that we're not going to be seen as oh
you're those guys from that thing i
watch because a lot of these people are
probably not watching good mythical
morning or listening to your biscuits
and that's fine
but I got to say that I go in with a
little with a chip on my shoulder and
I'm and I'm self-aware and I'm
self-conscious to begin with right it's
like when you met like we don't belong
you met Josh Brolin backstage it stand
up to cancer
a little holding room yeah we're all the
celebrities were let me tell you that
was the most celebrity I've ever been
around
I mean we got freakin Santos right there
right and then there was other there was
Sophia Sophia from Modern Family and
then you got Maria Menounos right over
here and just you know people that
people know Macaulay Culkin Macaulay
Culkin was in there so
and Josh Brolin is facing away from me
and I'm like gotta talk to him and maybe
take a picture and send it to my kids
because Lilly will freak out and you're
very good in this in this setting I I do
not enjoy I'm not good at just going up
and beginning to talk to people
literally left that room and I asked
Jenna to find you and bring you back it
was very crowded I'm a very big man I'm
like a I'm like a Great Dane in the
midst of a bunch of Chihuahuas and and
it just I feel out of place and I just I
got to get out man not only do you have
a chip on your shoulder but it's it is
at a high elevation yeah you can't even
see the chip because the shoulders above
your face
but yeah I'm self-conscious too so like
I I was like at the moment that I was
about to say Josh and get him to turn
around I was so nervous that I was
convinced that his name wasn't Josh yeah
so in your doubting yourself instead of
saying you know I get that like name
fright that I'm like I'm gonna say the
wrong name so instead of saying any name
at the last second I was like I don't
think his name is Josh and then my right
hand went up and grabbed his shoulder
you touch the knows shoulder I gret I
didn't tap it I grabbed it and I was
like gosh I didn't hey man and he turned
around and I was like I think I said I'm
a I'm a huge fan I just wanted to meet
you or something like that and then I
was like then you came over then I was
like can we get a selfie
and I was like Jenna was with us I was
like Jenna can you take his self he was
like get and then he laughed and said
she can't take a selfie because it'd
just be I thought oh that's a photo
right right but then you also said yeah
we're big on the Internet
and I said it as a self-deprecating it's
he didn't I mean I've known you for
quite some time right so I knew exactly
what you meant but I knew that in in
typical link fashion only link and me
knew what you meant and everyone around
did not write and so josh brolin says it
doesn't matter what he meant was I don't
need you to be big on the Internet to
take a picture with me right so then he
puts his arms raices but also kind of
embarrassed he puts his arms around her
and say to take this picture and then
somebody walks by and he's like these
guys are big on the Internet hey but I
got my picture mate yeah you did you did
we did it was a little blurry but it was
dark back there
yeah and that was that was ages ago but
but but you should've a point to then
say that was again going into this party
that we're now talking about yeah yeah
yeah I were squirrelly I like I know
that you're gonna initiate some
conversations with people and I'm
praying I'm gonna like get in on those
conversations so I'm thinking about that
a little bit but of course it's it's out
of this at a hotel and there's a bar so
sort of the first thing you do when you
get to a party like this is you go to
the bar and you get a drink right if
you're like walking around mingling you
don't have anything to eat or drink in
your hands it's like that just you seem
sad it's like you got to have you got to
be consuming something so that you feel
like I'm not just looking for someone to
talk to
yet I'm not telling you you can't have
two free hands at a party can if you've
got two free hands at a party you're
nothing but a threat you you just look
like a complete [ __ ] look at that guy
with two free hands he can do anything
he has he's got the advantage yeah bad
way he's doing nothing so that what a
beautiful purse who useless hands just
sitting there I bet I bet he's big on
the internet right period so I go to the
bar and let me say that I also I'm not
good at bar you know I'm not good at the
whole bar thing I thought I was fine at
bar and I'm sitting I'm right there
beside you I got my
but I got my elbow up you know it's like
I'm a little cash
yeah I'm not stiff about it and I and
you know again I'm always self-conscious
about how big I am I'm like everybody
can see me up here I'm towering over
everyone I've got this checkered suit on
well that was a mistake and now and
you're doing the lane so I started doing
the lean and then I see that there's all
these people at the bar and there's
three bartenders
and I just did the math really quickly
and I was like it's gonna take a while
to get the bartender's attention and
then get a drink and meanwhile I'm
seeing people from oh that's the that's
the dude from West world there's one of
the there's one of the women from
Handmaid's Tale you know the shows that
I enjoy I'm like this is pretty cool I'm
in a bar with these people that guy look
like a male stripper but with clothes on
hmm there are a lot of those type of guy
didn't I do it hey yeah I didn't notice
oh okay
interesting so I then begin to see that
the bartender is he's asking people to
what side of you and to the side of me
what they want and I'm like just kind of
I I'm we're both leaning in at this
point what what I was just waiting for
him to make eye contact eye contact and
ask what we would like that seems like a
reasonable expectation and then after 15
minutes of that not happening I start to
think well maybe we need to do something
like lean in more like can I should I
give more elbow like and you don't want
to make constant eye contact it wasn't
like I was following him like a hawk but
maybe and so I started doing that and
like I'm looking at you and like a
murmuring but I don't wanna I don't want
him to hear me murmuring cuz you don't
look desperate
if he gets you're already just big on
the internet that's he knows if he knows
that I'm murmuring about about him then
that Ginny zone he's probably not gonna
want to give me a drink at all and
that's why you then left me
well that was I mean that was another 15
minutes
no it wasn't thirty this is where we
waited there twenty minutes you may have
been there 20 minutes and then you left
and then no I looked on your face and
like I was getting angry I mean I know
when you're getting angry there it's
like your eyes started water a little
bit
and not an I'm about to cry kind of way
it's like I'm about to explode
okay a nice Kristi and Jesse were we're
talking they were right behind us and I
don't know it's just like you're there
with your woman and you can't even get
her a drink yeah and it's like I did I
got angry of the guy cuz then I feel
very small I felt like I was being
purposely avoided everybody around us
like multiple people were coming up
getting drinks eventually they'd wait
ten minutes and it wasn't like they were
fun they weren't flagging him down he
was just looking at them in a sad and he
had peripheral vision there's no doubt
that the man was seen as constantly in
his periphery yeah and then what is it
about us I was like yeah he knew we were
from the internet he saw us and he was
like there it is a big guy with a plaid
suit and his buddy from the internet
they're from the internet they're big on
the internet I'm not going to serve them
and of course we didn't actually think
that I'm joking but subconsciously you
start to search for any reason why this
jerk is not giving us yes so to make an
already long story so then a little
shorter you got you later implode so I
left link leaves of course now I had to
have to order off four drinks for
everyone now I'm gonna look like a total
douche and but then my wife comes up and
she's like why are you still here I'm
like the guy he's doing why the guy
won't take my order and I by that time I
said hey man can you help me after you
help this guy he was like and he was
like okay yeah what did he still didn't
do it this is just create then Jesse got
up there and Jesse because I was like
maybe it's he's just ignoring the men
she spoke to him she spoke to him he's
like okay and then another five minutes
pass and then he said comes back up to
her he takes the order and then another
ten minutes pass and he has made other
drinks for people and then Jesse is like
are you making our drinks and he's like
oh what did you want what
yeah how you not know this no I never
heard this story and I'm so angry about
absolutely no way it was not intention
all right I want to learn no way this is
what I want what I thought I wanted to
learn was how to do bar but now what
I've learned is if that happens to me
next time I'm gonna ask the guy was like
why are
you not asking me if I want to drink
yeah I mean and what am I missing
bartender like somebody and maybe if you
know hashtag ear biscuits if you're a
bartender please let me know what you
think we're doing wrong and you don't
you can say because I don't worry rude
you can say perhaps and then tweet at us
so that you're not making us feel like
idiots but I I just wish we would have
asked the guy like grabbed him by the
collar and choked him till he almost
died and then let him go at the last
second and ask him that's why did you
not make us a drink that's a little
excessive yeah I don't think we should -
we should grab him man I don't do that
yeah but I would have just asked him I
went to another bar not a drink is there
a Hanson it was a second bar is there a
hansom is there a wink is there a
whistle is a whistle system I didn't
hear anybody else whistle I don't know I
don't do bar well I'm embarrassed about
it my theory is we were not talking to
each other or anyone else we were just
waiting to order a drink and it seemed
desperate we seemed we stared at him too
much and he didn't like it and he wanted
to teach us some sort of lesson well he
did we won't but do that again so
ironically with this youtuber creator
chip on our shoulder we're going to dive
into what it means to be burned out with
so many youtubers experienced in it
along with us over the years of our
career but first we do want to take a
short break and let you know that you
can grab this shirt
not a sponsor at mythical dot store one
of us could have worn it but link
insisted on going with his plain brown
shirt and I insisted on going I'm a
plain Navy shirt look what we are we
wouldn't budge so we have to hold up the
shirt that we want you to purchase you
can't purchase a plain navy shirt in
mythical dust or or a plain pocketed
brown tee in mythical that store if
you'd like us to sell those let us know
in the meantime we have a lot of other
things
mythical dot store support internet
Ament I've watched a lot of videos read
a few articles over the past hour in
preparation for this discussion
and I you know I will say we rarely
speak into the YouTube community in
terms of like things that youtubers are
discussing like we because you know good
mythical morning is not really the venue
for us to talk about those things we're
not that type of content creator I'm
glad that we're having this discussion
but you know I really feel for I I just
found myself in a you know in place
where I I'm just feeling for people all
these youtubers are saying they're
burned out now we'll say as a side note
I'm also still looking for looking
through all the youtuber suggestions
YouTube content suggestions of things
that we need to be watching that we will
actually personally enjoy and find our
little corner of YouTube I thought we
were gonna talk about it in this episode
this airdate but now we're gonna talk
about it on the next one so thanks for
all your suggestions we're watching and
we are getting to that but yeah and for
right now we're just talking about this
for those of you who don't know exactly
we're talking about I'll give you a
quick rundown quick summary so many
different youtubers this is not a recent
phenomenon necessarily people youtubers
have been talking about being burned out
trying to maintain relevance on YouTube
for a while but like link said earlier
the mainstream media has begun to notice
this year especially and there's been a
lot of articles about it and actually
YouTube has been engaged directly with
this and Robert Kensal has been it has
said you know he's responded to this he
sat down with Caspar Lee a content
creator and answered a bunch of
questions about YouTube and this was one
of them talked about burnout do you have
any advice
folks races to avoid burnout so we're
gonna get to like YouTube's response to
this to this crisis which really is a
crisis and a little bit but essentially
the basics are that there are certain
aspects of the YouTube platform it's
probably best summarized as the YouTube
platform specifically the YouTube
algorithm which suggests videos for you
to watch rewards people who are highly
engaged
with her audience and create consistent
content and it is the very reason that
we ended up doing good mythical morning
starting in 2012 and it's the reason
that we've built a company it's the
reason that we're talking to you right
now from this studio it's because we got
really really lucky and kind of in in
sort of backed our way into creating
daily content that was the right length
that was the right time right place
rewarded by the algorithm and now
everyone has sort of seen that one of
the tried and true formulas for
remaining relevant on YouTube is to make
a steady stream of content ideally daily
at least a few times a week on a regular
schedule that doesn't have any breaks
and that expectation has led to a lot of
people feeling like they cannot stop
giving themselves to their audience and
if they do they're gonna fade away into
obscurity
and what's happened because the Machine
you know put this little slice of the of
the theory because you guess as a
creator how the Machine of the YouTube
algorithm works hmm
in a lot of ways in one of those ways is
well if if you have a certain rhythm and
then you change that and you know so
your channel goes dark for a few days or
a week or a month or because you want to
take a break is it good is it not
literally going to be served up your
video is not gonna be served up as much
to that audience anymore so it's and
that struggle has led directly to the
mental breakdown of a number of
high-profile youtubers who have made
videos about the meltdowns the burnouts
that they are they are having I realized
last night that I I can't keep doing the
blogs it was like emotionally it was
just a lot I just felt like my brain was
just tapped out on the inside you feel
like just like breaking down and they've
taken breaks they've quit they've left
the platform or they've just been very
vulnerable with their audience and kind
of explained what's going on
and now YouTube is
basically being called out by a number
of publications what YouTube what are
you going to do about this crisis and I
will say another factor that's not the
YouTube algorithm but something
something that happens with a lot of
audiences is that they get really upset
if if you don't keep your rhythm like if
you have a day leave if you're a gamer
who has daily video or three videos a
day jacksepticeye for example he has
multiple videos a day and then you feel
like you got to stop you'll get
complaints from your audience I'm not
saying he got complaints but I think he
anticipated that there certainly have
been other creators over the years who
have you know you you you'll see them
you'll see creators miss a day or miss
their rhythm and then they have to post
an apology video because not to
algorithm but their audience comes after
them with vitriol is that a word they
upset so I will say that's another
factor it's not just the the machine
yeah and I so related to that I have
seen and the majority of fans when these
people have come out and said I'm having
a breakdown I have to stop the majority
of fans have been supportive now a not
not very very small but very very vocal
minority has basically said pull your
pants up man
you know firstworldproblems you're
living the dream you're sitting in your
bedroom making videos and now you're
complaining about how you're having a
burnout and III think most of you guys
listening to your biscuits probably
don't even need to have that explain
what that's that's a ridiculous
perspective on this because if these are
these people are not making this up
they're dealing with very very real
issues that have resulted from this
expectation that has been placed on them
we're gonna get into a little bit of the
ins and outs of of what might be
contributing to that
I will say that you know so being a
successful youtuber is an incredible
privilege and the factors that lead to
popularity are very often outside of the
creator's control I kind of hinted at
that early earlier we've talked about
this before
there's the entertainment business is is
as a whole but also on YouTube it's just
YouTube isn't is another side of it
there's just so many things that you
can't control you can't anticipate and
that will lead to your sudden relevance
and popularity mm-hmm that doesn't
there's there's a lot more people
working very very hard for a very long
time then there are those that break
through and somehow make it to the
quote-unquote top and we have somehow
managed to maintain relevance for a very
long time and hard work has been a big
part of it but pure luck the right place
right time has been a huge part of it as
well
right hard work from me luck for you and
yes a great combination right it works
but I will say this is not easy okay
I'm speaking for us I'm also speaking
for other youtubers who have who do this
for a living
this is not an easy business engineering
was much easier being an engineer was
for me personally significantly less
stressful significantly less
time-consuming
significantly less difficult than being
a youtuber okay oh yeah not even not
even in the same ballpark so I do so you
said cuz a lot of people would be like
what you're just as easy you're doing
something you're living the drink yes we
are living the dream it is not easy so I
do want to say that right up front I
think it's important to understand
and I'm I'm you know I would imagine
that anyone who starts their own
business like starts a restaurant I hear
how difficult that is that that makes
sense to me you know I felt like there's
you know it's a great analogy
we're starting our we start now on
business every it's ab is been
absolutely up to us and for the longest
time it was just us and it's like
opening a restaurant but you are the
restaurant you know what I'm saying
yeah you had like if you want to run a
successful restaurant you have to be
there there I can't think of any
examples of people opening restaurants
and not being there every night very few
examples that's what it takes to be
successful at a restaurant but what if
you were the restaurant that that's it
that's a perfect comparison right so I
mean for us it was I mean this okay
we've got to make it go at this this is
this is what we're trying to do we've
got we got families we've got kids we
got mouths to feed
we're we're putting up videos and we had
I mean early on we hadn't discovered the
daily rhythm of of good mythical morning
and it was it was nerve wracking back
then when it was one video a month that
you know had to top the last one and it
and you could up you could spend all
this time and effort and money and pour
yourself into it and then there could be
a glitch or something with YouTube and
then it's like nobody sees it or it it
severely underperforms
and you're going from video to video
that way well I mean so we have the
luxury of good mythical morning being
what it is now yeah but I mean I very
much relate to the gamers who were
putting up videos every day you know
Shaun jacksepticeye he was in here he
he's he took a break and prepared his
audience so I just need a little bit of
time a little bit of time to find that
energy and motivation again and it you
know he sadly he had to be apologetic
about it I just wish you know that it
kind of had that tone of an apology when
it's like you know what he's making a
decision a strong decision for his own
mental health to take a break and he's
and he's communicating properly that's
something to be celebrated but he he
made a video every day for like over
four years and then he talked about
there were weeks at a time when he
didn't leave his house at all he blogged
about it he told me about it when we
were at the sink trying trying to wash
that nasty smell off our hands after we
shot it yeah of the intestines and I
mean I relate to that even now it's like
it's a position of privilege to have
some millions of people watching every
single day but it's this pressure that
like okay when's it when is it gonna
decline when is it gonna stop when am I
going to I can't let go of this thing
because the bottom could fall out
I very much relate to that and I think
that's you know not you know and when I
was comparing it to engineering earlier
again this is for me personally I'm not
saying they're not engineers out there
who work harder than I do but I'm saying
that Rhett the engineer versus Rhett the
youtuber there's not a comparison it's
not just about the hours I mean it is
the hours partly there's we spend a lot
more time on this than we did as
engineers but it is the personal tie to
it because it is you it is you putting
yourself out there it is you as we joke
often and it's kind of a joke but not
really the reason it's funny is because
it's true you have a tendency to want to
construct yourself image out of the
audience's reaction to you and you begin
to become the you that has been created
in the eye of the audience and the in
that audience expects you to be a
certain way because they got in at a
certain point you did something at a
certain point in their lives and there
is this really unhealthy codependence
between a creator and the audience
it is like the the perfect picture of
codependency
I mean Philip DeFranco he talked about
how your self-worth becomes
connected to how many people are
watching you and then if it's not that
you have 800,000 views on this video
it's that you had a million on the one
yesterday or the one last week and now
it's what is this an indication of
something of a of the bottom starting to
drop out of this thing and that
relationship I would argue is the the
setting for mental unhealthiness in both
parties especially both the creator and
the audience because we hear and here's
another go ahead I was gonna say off
people say all the time and I'm
incredibly grateful I'm incredibly
grateful that people say that something
that we created actually made a tangible
difference in their life and their
emotional or mental life it's incredible
again never intended for that to be the
case was just trying to make people
laugh but the way that this community
has been built and this isn't true just
of us it's true of many different
youtubers you start to feel if you take
that away you're you're hurting but if
someone means building at least
subconscious if someone is building
their self-image and their emotional
health around your content and then
they're setting themselves up for just
big of a burnout as you're going is
you're gonna experience when you quit
giving them the content it's just not
it's not a healthy thing for either
party to view their mental health in
light of the content and regardless of
what side you're on and sometimes when
you start to experience this dynamic you
make creative decisions that make it
worse you know Felix PewDiePie hee hee
he was talking about the dynamic of well
if your views start to slip then you
start to try things to connect more to
drop the facade maybe cry on camera get
more personal share even more of
yourself because that works as a and
that can that very easily becomes
dangerous when it's like you know
you're giving more of yourself in order
to stave stave off the turning tide you
know in the the that the verge article I
don't know if you read that I was
reading it they talked about an
expectation of upbeat intimacy so
there's this pull between okay you've
got to be somebody publicly who's who's
so authentic and giving everything to
your audience but you got to be happy
about it or ironically you can play the
I'm falling apart and this is my poi you
know right to to recapture even when
somebody when somebody has a breakdown
and they come back but they make the
video about the breakdown and then they
come back and they are different they're
transformed they're more raw they're
more real again the tendency of humans
is for the Creator to begin to find
their identity in that and their new
self that they've created for their
audience and their audience begins to
find some sort of comfort in this new
person that they're getting their
entertainment from again we're talking
about the very negative side of this
because the overwhelming majority of the
the relationship that we have with our
fans and what we get from our fans is
positive so don't I don't don't think
that I'm painting this as this is this
is a bad thing well it's ultimately a
very good thing but what we're
describing what what I'm hearing from
other creators I think it is good to to
describe our actual experience yeah yeah
you know so because there's always a
tendency towards making unhealthy
decisions and you know we've tried to
navigate that over the decade yeah well
unless so I've shared a little bit about
a few of these things but I'll kind of
give you the whole the whole context
here of kind of what happened to me last
year so as you know in was it October
when do we start the new version of good
mythical morning that's when it came out
yeah okay so Eve you know the new
version of good mythical morning so one
year ago which we called internally we
called it GMM 22 the reason we call it
that is because it was
season of YouTube was unlike every
season before when that season of GMM
yeah that season of GMM unlike every
season of GMM before was financed by
YouTube so YouTube said you're not going
to be doing the Adsense thing that
you've been doing we want to come in and
we want to pay you guys to make this
show and here's what we want to do we're
gonna give you this money to make the
show but we're gonna give you the kind
of money that you would be getting to
make a television show and we want to
make the content add up to at least 22
minutes a day and we want it to be
multiple segments every single day again
we talked all about it last year people
were like you guys are trying to make
more Adsense well the reality is YouTube
came and said we want to pay you guys to
make more segments every single day and
so we said this is a great experiment
we've been looking for something to
shake things up let's do it and nothing
about YouTube approaching us with that
opportunity
we're not critical of them doing that in
any way no no no jump to the opportunity
and we are we are we are not now
critical I have absolutely zero regrets
about it it was all it well it is it was
difficult I'm gonna tell you why it was
difficult but we would never go back and
not do it because it led to a rat right
now now here's what here's what happened
there was kind of a combination of
things that happen at end of the year so
you know we had our book that we've been
working on we had season 2 a buddy
system that we were working on we had
the new gmm that we were getting ready
for and I'm probably not even thinking
about something else that we were
working on but basically we were packing
every single hour of every single day
within reason I don't know how many
hours we ended up working a week it
probably averaged out to 60 to 70 or
something like that with all these
entertainment responsibilities and then
this new GMM came along and it took an
incredible amount of time but it also
wasn't you remember this it wasn't
received well by a lot of people
eventually it kind of leveled out and
people were happy for the most part but
we got we've had a lot of backlashes
over different things but there was a
there was a backlash we tried to address
it right here on ear biscuits people
saying things like
guys just put it in one video guys just
put it in one video and then also post
all the other videos on their own
I like the a vet brothers say people
love to talk about things they don't
know about I was obviously upset about
it people thought I was being super
defensive and I was criticized for that
I didn't deal with that very well but
the probably the bigger thing other than
feeling like something we were doing
wasn't working was just how much we had
done last year and how much we were
signing up for that I knew would just
continue right into January so a couple
things to happen you remember I was
struggling with this like throat thing
in the fall thought it was allergies
thought it was acid reflux never really
pinpointed exactly what it was but it
was new it never happened before I
remember making fun of you yeah and then
the second thing that happened was we're
kind of right in the middle of a
shooting GMM I was sitting there reading
an email one day and I was like I can't
see this email like it's distorted and I
like look at my eyes and realize there's
something wrong with one of my eyes long
story short I get diagnosed with a
condition called central serous
retinopathy which is a temporary
condition retinopathy retinopathy in
which the basically the back of your eye
right where the retina comes in to your
eye where the nerve comes the the nerve
comes in the eye sort of filled up with
fluid it's detached a little bit kind of
the same symptoms that you would have in
a detached retina and it's temporary
like 80% of the time is temporary and
healed Hills on it on its own lasts
about six months or so and this
condition was observed so that we was
sort of first recognized when World War
two pilots were coming back from the war
and many of these pilots who had been in
these incredible stressful situations
had this condition so the literature is
a little split on this but it's lots of
slots there's a lot to suggest that it's
stress-related I knew at the time that
it was stress-related because to us
having these physical problems kind of
mount up I was thinking I don't know how
we're going to keep up with a schedule
I'm looking to
18 and thinking it's gonna be crazy and
my wife says you have to go to therapy
you are manifesting all this stress
physically which is a real thing and
you've got to deal with this a next year
cannot be like this year so I mean
there's a lot of promises I made one of
the reasons that we didn't have a huge
project in the middle of the summer this
year is because we both told our wives
that 2018 is not gonna be like 2017 we
overcommitted mm-hmm but I also knew
that it was like there was so much
building that I needed professional help
my mental and emotional health was
beginning to suffer my physical health
was beginning to suffer because of my
emotional health and I knew that I
needed to talk to somebody about it so
started going to therapy
I'm still in it still going still going
to therapy it's been incredibly helpful
sort of the the one-two punch is
beginning to deal directly with some of
those issues that I was having
coupled with us changing though our
approach to our schedule which is
something we've had to reevaluate
multiple times throughout our career
which we can get into in a second but
that's that was my last year so when I
when I read about these guys burning out
I'm like I totally relate would you we
just had all had a breakdown of certain
sort and probably as big of a breakdown
as I have had yes personally I don't
think I've had what is a true mental
breakdown before but it was the most
significant the most significant stress
got me worse than it than it ever has
well I should say if it if you're going
blind I should say so
yeah but that's but that that's I mean
that's one of the things I'm dealing
with in therapy is like I am so I have a
shell that's super independent and super
self-reliant so and I constructed that
for reasons that I'm still figuring out
but one of the ways I get through things
is I just
9 I'm dealing with something and then it
manifests in a different way as opposed
to just being honest and saying I am
working too hard I am tying myself up in
this too much
I just I'm like you know what I'm fine
I'm fine I just can't see can't talk got
back problems stomach problems lots of
digestive things were happening I'm
better I'm not cured I'm just don't
worry I am in a much better place than I
was in because of a combination of
therapy and just changes that we've made
I mean I said I certainly experienced
all the same stresses of being stretched
way too thin and feeling like you know a
lot of it is things that we sign up for
creatively we need to we feel like we
owe it to ourselves to to do it the best
we can so it's not just about meeting
audience expectations right but I
absolutely I mean I remember always
being fearful when we would take a break
at from good method from releasing good
mythical morning episodes at the end of
the year like right around Christmas
time through the beginning of the year
that would correspond with us taking a
holiday break or over the summer when we
would take longer breaks I get very very
anxious yeah about not what we were
doing but when we were decided not to do
it you know so it's it the stress came
on both sides I'm grateful that we did
take those breaks but it was the breaks
we're just as difficult as working so
hard for me because of the anxiety of
what's gonna happen am I you know am i
pulling putting a bullet in you know the
brain of our performance
you know we waving the white flag to
some algorithm opponent you know it's it
can drive you it can drive you crazy I
mean I I found
I would feel that a lot I'd feel that
every time we would consider a break and
how do we mitigate it or let's just you
know but I mean we the I do think that
we bypassed a lot as bad as it got and I
mean you just quantified that that was
that's really bad well and I mean yeah
and I know where you're going could have
gotten a lot worse would have been well
first of all we would have never been in
a position to even experience to even
say yes to what used to best is to do
and and and say yes to all those
projects that we did last year without a
lot of the decisions that we had made
that Nessa weren't all weren't this
great foresight and some of it was
foresight but a lot of it was just the
way that our lives were and I think this
is where we kind of want to get into
some of the things that we have done and
continue to do to mitigate this burnout
problem in our own lives and our own
careers well I mean you want to talk
about
good morning Chia Lincoln first sure I
think whenever we decided we didn't you
know putting out one video on a
rhettandlink channel every month that
was our that was our main strategy and
then we were trying to make a we're
trying to turn our local commercials
into a television show we were trying to
get that project off the ground it
eventually became commercial Kings on
IFC but we didn't know that at the time
and you know as that was we're trying to
finagle that and get it going we decided
to do more concealer content on our
second channel but we conceptualized it
as good morning Chia Lincoln so it was
just a talk show it was basically the
good good mythical morning format which
I mean you probably have heard this
story a million times of how Chia
Lincoln turned into good mythical
morning but we decided to put that Chia
Lincoln on the table and check in with
the progress and we said when the chia
pet dies
good morning Chia Lincoln is over right
and we did that because what we thought
we were gonna make a show called
commercial kings and that actually
happened we thought we were gonna be
moving to LA for amount of time
that was the main reason we did that but
this but this but we used we came up
with that creative device because we
knew we had to prepare the audience who
who may or may not show up to watch this
thing that hey if you start liking this
thing a lot it is going to end because
well we didn't say because we're gonna
make a television show we said because
that's just the idea that's the creative
idea that Chia Pets gonna die well and I
would I mean and so it gave us an out so
there wasn't a like it we weren't
overwhelmed with frustration Moratti
yeah we didn't want to commit to
something that we were like I don't know
how this is gonna go this could get old
real fast so let's not let's not
overcome it yeah cuz we were very
nervous about doing a date yes so any we
never we never thought about doing like
a daily vlog type thing we started we
were doing vlog we would not do them
every yeah so and even though those were
very success I don't know in YouTube I
don't know how our advice is going to
apply to someone who's doing a daily
vlog I don't think it's advice it's just
what we did our experience I don't know
how you can apply our experience to
daily vlog because we would we would
never do a daily vlog we will never do a
daily vlog I will say this conversation
is brought to you by chia pet but a chia
pet duck no it's not a sponsor yeah not
a sponsor this shirt the shirt this
whole conversation was just to sell
something be pretty pathetic it would be
sad
but I would say even before that because
because I think one of the most
important things you can do to mitigate
burnout is scheduling right and so this
is something that we walked into because
of the how old we were and what our life
stage was when we sort of began doing
this full-time so we were already and
we've been doing this since 2006 that's
12 years ago so I was 28 years old at
the time I already had kids or a kid we
really had no business doing it for that
reason so we were already pretty old so
you know we were our brains were fully
formed which happens about 26 so we were
who we are in a lot of ways we had
families we had structure we had regular
jobs before this so there was this
expectation that you're going to go
Oh from your home to a job for a certain
amount of time and you're gonna come
back and so when we made the decision to
be full-time bean youtubers it was from
the beginning we were like we can't do
this to the house this has to be we can
gotta find an office we found a place
where we could work and that the old
basement in Lillington and we went in
every single day at a certain time and
we came home in a certain day at a
certain time again that wasn't because
we anticipated that being a youtuber was
gonna be really hard and eventually lead
to burnout it was just well this is the
structure we have in our families
already so that one sort of we have
wives and kids do we want to see that
one default decision to fit our youth
our entertainment careers into a
nine-to-five essentially which really
isn't really 9:00 to 5:00 but you know
it's basically the same every day that
was the smartest unintentional decision
we've ever made because it didn't spill
out too much into something that we were
constantly doing or thinking about at
home we weren't sitting there at night
at the house editing videos while our
kids were not with us or whatever it was
it was contained well we we worked one
late night a week and then sometimes we
slept at the office on Thursday night
and we we worked all day all night
Thursday and all day Friday and then we
came home but we at least kept it to
that one night yeah and as was our
commitment as things continued to build
up until where they're at now we've
always tried to schedule things
incredibly efficiently to fit into a
window now we've talked about this
before you've heard us we've said it in
public many times we do not shoot good
mythical morning every single day and we
would never ever be dumb enough to try
to do that
we did that with Chia Lincoln and we did
it for 40 days and then yeah and we knew
we weren't gonna do that again so we
knew we couldn't make good mythical
morning topical so that we didn't have
to do it every single day and I'm not
saying it would be dumb for somebody to
make a video
day it would be dumb for these two
douchebags right here to try to make a
video every single day we know ourselves
well enough to know that we would we
would kill each other or someone if we
tried to do good mythical morning every
single day and our and our wives would
probably kill us
yeah because sometimes we so we would
like what say well we can shoot it we
can shoot a handful at a time and
sometimes we would start that and then
the second one wouldn't go well if we
were let's say we were gonna try to
shoot three and like the second one
wouldn't go well and when we're in your
basement
I'm not basement when we were in your
garage shooting they are at that card
table we we get at each other's throats
and they may be like ah let's just go to
lunch and then we go to lunch and then
we come back and be like I have enough
shootin anything else today I'm a bit
too frustrated yeah well and you're
talking about cuz because I want to get
back to the scheduling thing because the
other thing that we've done in
conjunction with as things have have
gained momentum is as early as we
possibly could we've gotten help we've
shared responsibilities we stopped
editing our show as early as we thought
we could to get somebody else to do it
because we were just feeling the
pressure already we here right here at
this table we interviewed many content
creators who were already successful who
were already making way more than enough
money to pay somebody to edit their
videos but still insisted on I can't do
it I can't give that said I can't I you
have to choose you have to choose
between complete creative control or
mental health that may be a
controversial statement but I believe
that if you're going to do this for a
living you have to make a choice between
those two things you have to give up
some control and get some freaking help
and you can afford it more than you
think you can even if you're a
small-time youtuber you can afford
somebody to come in and help you with
certain aspects of your production find
a way to do it your mental health is
important enough to make that happen I
do want to yeah I want to back that up I
mean I was looking at boogies vlog about
just before coming in here and he
acknowledged you know it's it's not just
top creators there's people there's
creators who were living paycheck to
paycheck and I think a lot of people
equate this problem to money you got to
keep in mind not every youtuber is rich
and if they see from video to video that
it's dropped by thousands of views
well that translates into not not being
able to buy groceries you know so it's
it's freaking scary you know and we have
the luxury of not being at that place
anymore but we were yeah I mean we were
at that place and it's you know so I I
just want to acknowledge that that you
know there's there's creators going
paycheck to paycheck but you can't you
know you can't put a price tag on your
on your mental health yeah and I ain't I
mean yeah good that was it well in terms
of the scheduling thing again I don't
know how this translates to somebody
like ninja who streams every single day
he's got a stream every day cuz that's
his job that's what he's signed up for I
don't think it's it's ultimately
sustainable there are but listen there
are and we told him that yeah there are
sweet up we told him what we're just
telling you but there are super patient
care of yourself but I so what I will
say is you got okay
Charles Trippy he's holds the world
record for daily vlogs and I haven't
spoken to Charles in a while but I he's
and he's a very tough my guys been
through brain surgery he blogged it he's
a very tough minded individual and there
are some anomalies who are capable of
this kind of thing in the same way that
LeBron James is capable of what he is as
an athlete but don't assume that you're
LeBron James assume that you're somewhat
normal and that's the assumption that
we've always made is that I probably
have about an average capacity for
stress and for the amount of stuff that
I can fit into my day I have to get
sleep I'm not one of these people that
can get four hours of sleep I got to get
seven eight hours of sleep every night
to be healthy so scheduling has been
incredibly important to us this might
blow your mind this may blow your
so if you're doing something that you
can schedule GMM is a Daily Show but
because it's not live and it's not a
daily vlog it can be scheduled I believe
that our record there was a time when we
shot eight episodes of good mythical
morning in one day eight episodes in one
day we were getting ready for a buddy
system yeah I was gonna say and then we
and then we turned around and then we
shot buddy system it's not you know so
it was nuts
and then we actually wasn't a healthy
choice but slot buddy system and then
and then made like 20 more episodes but
it helped prove to us that we can we can
clump together episodes in order to then
have space in our brains in our lives in
our professional lives yeah for other
things we could figure that we you know
we started to figure that out and
something that we thought always you
know doing when we started bickering
because we couldn't shoot two episodes
back-to-back well we you know we figured
it out yeah we just figured it out so we
don't know when we got qualified people
the mythical crew and we built that team
over time to help us out and it's
something that you know we tweaked and
tweaked and tweaked because we we just
continued we're continually reminded of
okay hold on let's stop for a second
let's evaluate what do we need to change
in our production schedule in order to
maintain we're in charge to maintain our
our personal health we well yeah the
decision we made is that our health
would be a factor a very significant
factor in the scheduling of what we do
that we've done over 1400 episodes of
good mythical morning and we do two
seasons a year we do a summer season
there's vit there's a few weeks in a
couple places around the the year where
we're not making content but I can
safely say at least right now now the
schedule for last season with the
multiple segments a day that was not
sustained
well that isn't what that isn't why we
didn't continue doing it we didn't
continue doing it because YouTube
decided that they didn't want to keep
doing the show in that way which was
fine the reason we went back to this
current version was because they decided
they didn't want to do the long version
so now it's back to the way it always
was independent we're completely in
charge and we which is best for us
that's for us grateful for that and but
we said we are going to approach this in
a way that places our health because our
health our emotional mental health
physical health all that translates back
into our creative potential our ability
to do the things and first of all it
helps you and you can be a better
husband you can be a better father all
those things are going to be important
but when you're talking about from a
business perspective we have to have
that health in order to be able to do a
show that you want to watch to be able
to make a podcast that you want to
listen to to be able to write a book
that you want to read be able to watch a
show that so yeah so I I appreciate and
I just want to applaud every creator
who's coming forward and saying you know
what I am going to take a break or I'm
gonna you know I'm gonna I'm gonna make
some sort of a change either for a few
weeks or longer
that and I'm not gonna apologize for it
you know so I applaud everybody who's
done that I don't know everybody like
but when when Sean did that that was
that was great you know in I was
watching a 283 Ethan and ILA's one of
their recent videos where they said you
know Ethan said I just have accepted
that I'm like actually depressed I'm
depressed I am this is what I'm working
through this is why I haven't been
making content you know on our YouTube
channel that's what he was saying
and I applaud him and everybody who
comes forward and says you know what I'm
making this this is the healthy decision
for me it it actually the flip side of
that is it bothers me that it has to
be an apologetic tone you know III could
just I could I could sense in the way
that he was talking that he just felt
you know I mean they were coming off of
some other issue with they were they
were beat up about their their video
game release and a Phil forum related to
that and you know it but but then it's
like you know I just felt sad that there
was a tinge of an apologetic tone insane
hey I'm doing what's best for me and you
as an audience member you know I'm sorry
that I can't give you what you want you
know it's and I read a lot of the
comments and was encouraged that there
was a lot of support there and I you
know I want to echo that to them that I
think the again I don't majority was
enjoy fans are very supportive but they
also a lot of people don't realize a lot
of fans don't realize how the
expectations they placed on creators has
contributed to this problem it's an
innocent it's almost unfair for them to
expect but I think that's I think
there's an application for fans because
you do now understand you've heard it
from so many different people that there
is this unrealistic expectation that you
will be given exactly what you want when
you want it from everyone you want it
from and it comes it comes at a cost to
the health of the creator's who are
giving that to you yeah before that's a
factor before the internet everything
was seasoned like I'm so grateful that
we called good mythical morning seasons
because we knew we were going home to
see family for a break and we weren't
gonna make videos because we weren't
gonna be together so we started calling
them seasons but like all these gamers
and vloggers and creators it's just like
an an endless commitment and it's
ridiculous I mean it's a ridiculous
expectation and so if you I was telling
Sean's like just call him season you
know I wanted to help him so badly but
he's helping himself he doesn't need my
help but
just to shift gears here because you
know we're we're round in the final turn
I think the question is what what role
does YouTube have to play what is our
opinion about how much of this is
YouTube's fault or is on YouTube to fix
because a lot of the articles that are
out there now so YouTube's not doing
enough about YouTube's not doing enough
this that virgia article being the most
recent one I have a potentially
unpopular opinion about this hmm and
I've got okay so we may agree is this
YouTube's fault well yes in one sense
but is it YouTube's responsibility to
fix the problem of burnout now to their
credit they have addressed it publicly
several different people's over
different different employees have
talked about it I mean they got like a
they've got videos from Kati Morton who
they put on one of their official
channels which was which are helpful and
in there well and let Robert Kinsel said
you can take a break you will not be
penalized there's plenty of examples of
people taking breaks and coming back and
not suffering a loss in views you're not
really the algorithm doesn't punish you
okay
I don't want to get into the ins and
outs of the algorithm but I ultimately
want what I want to say is YouTube is
going to be in the business one way or
another of rewarding engagement there's
just no other way that this works people
automatically it's it this whole thing I
this whole thing is driven by getting
more people to watch more videos so they
can see more ads so Google can make more
money that is for better or worse in
this particular economy that is how this
system works and it's not going to
change anytime soon so they can make
some changes they can offer resources
they can tweak the algorithm so it
doesn't penalize you but the
responsibility
of handling this problem is not on
YouTube it is on you as a creator you
are ultimately responsible plant hope
for the best plan for the worst hope
that YouTube will do something that will
help this problem so you can confidently
take breaks and worry about your own
mental health but don't plan on it what
you need to do is to take your life into
your own hands and your schedule into
your own hands and your business into
your own hands and make some decisions
that put you first put your mental
health first and listen I don't want to
we make what is YouTube cos supposed to
do I'm I don't know yeah I I don't I
don't know that business I don't know
how it works and so I want YouTube to do
everything that they can to be helpful
and I and I hope that they will but
that's it's in their best interest I'm
not laying the blame or the
responsibility on them they need to show
up and in the way that they can but you
can't wait around for YouTube to change
something so then you can change
something about yourself you have to
make those changes first and yourself
and I just want to say quickly ok we're
especially I have a tendency to get
preachy I apologize for that I'm not
saying that we've got this figured out I
just told you that in within the
calendar year I had physical problems
thought I was going blind and had to go
to therapy I don't have this figured out
we got lucky we made a lot of decisions
by default based on other life
circumstances we're just telling you
what we learned I'm not saying that you
have to do this I'm not saying that if
you do this it's gonna be ok I'm not
saying that we're never gonna have
another burnout it could happen tomorrow
all I'm saying is that this is what our
experience has told us and I do feel
strongly that my mental health is my
responsibility and so I have to get off
my ass and take responsibility for it
now it took people it took physical
problems it took my wife saying you have
to go to therapy but ultimately I had to
make the decision to actually do it
myself so I don't think that we should
be late I don't think we should be just
sitting around wait twiddling our thumbs
waiting for you to
do something about this that's all a
saying I don't I I think they can do
their part just like hopefully we're
contributing to a change in cultural
expectations of the audience it's like I
appreciate you listening as a YouTube
viewer and maybe that changes the type
of comment that you would leave when a
creator disappoints you
with taking a break or so you know just
to be very Ortega takes a break without
apologizing or without letting you know
be sympathetic you never know what's
going on and and for the creators the
other thing I'd add is that yeah yeah
you have to get to a place where first
of all being a successful youtuber does
not equal happiness I am NOT happier now
then I was twelve years ago before we
started this success and Happiness are
largely unrelated all every single all
the research all the science points to
the fact that you basically return to
your default baseline happiness after
all kinds of different life life
circumstances lottery winners very
quickly return back to a baseline
happiness that they were before they won
the lottery and youtubers who experience
sudden or long-term success return back
to the same baseline happiness because
your happiness is not dependent upon
success so if you're thinking that being
recognized and being relevant is going
to lead to happiness you're just plain
wrong so I think that you know happiness
comes from being in healthy
relationships from serving people from
worrying about your own mental health
from taking breaks from that there's a
lots of different things that actually
do contribute to happiness and those are
things that you can do whether you're
youtuber or not but if you are a content
creator if those things are not present
in your life and the only thing is this
complete lie that we all believe that if
more people like me if I break that
number of subscribers that I set up as
this is this alter I will be happy
you will not be happy you will be less
happy if you begin looking for happiness
and things that are completely outside
of your control when when Felix released
his video months ago about this you know
his conclusion was so as a creator if
we're talking to creators at this point
just do you know just create things that
you're passionate about stay engaged of
course I agree with that but I also
think that when you're running a
business like starting your own
restaurant or wherever is at a certain
point you're also trying to make a
living and so I think that you've still
got a you got a factor in you got a
factor in your mental health and your
quality of life separate from your
content and your relationship with your
audience what you were saying and then
do things to to mitigate the the ways
that your videos may perform your
channel may perform poorly when you take
breaks for your own health and so I do
think that YouTube can continue to equip
creators to make sound business
decisions in that way and it's like okay
can you can't can you
can you here's case studies like I mean
we presented our good mythical morning
as a case study hey we bat shoot
sometimes we did eight extremely we did
eight episodes in a day you know these
types of things like just trying to
still make as much money as you can it's
not just about being a pure artist and
having to okay I the way for me to be
healthy is to only make things for
myself that people just as a by chance
as a byproduct enjoy I know let's also
say it is a business you're a business
owner and you've got it you know you've
got a you got to make sound business and
personal decisions together and that's
the component of it yeah yeah definitely
yeah any and you will get burned out
you assume that it's going to happen and
how do you turn the corner when it
happens and and headed off at the past
so it doesn't happen in an extreme
fashion yeah
and when you listen when you get help
you have to worry about those people
getting burned out too you know
yeah that's something that we have to
think about with with the people who
work on the mythical crew is that you
know are we are we spreading them too
thin are we asking too much of any one
individual so it's just something you
yeah it's so easily set aside because it
does it's you can't because you can't
put a price on it
you can't put a price on it you know you
cannot quantify mental health and it as
an as a dollar sign as a dollar amount
but and we wrestle with it I meaning in
conclusion the it's there's not an
absolute conclusion we wrestle with it
every week yesterday we were told
yesterday in just the private
conversation between the two of us is
like you know we've we've continued to
make changes to our production schedule
in order to give us more room to like if
we wanted to go surfing you know I think
we talked about it on this podcast when
we were coming out of that horrible time
it's like we're trying to create more
space for to get creatively energized by
doing things just for the fun of it yeah
and I said yesterday I was like as much
changes as we've made even since then
drastic ones to our production schedule
we're still hard-pressed to find time
for ourselves and it's like and so we
continue to fight for it and it's and
it's a result of success so I'm very
grateful for that at this point in our
careers but I'm just making the point
that it's a constant battle and you got
to be aggressive about it you got to get
ahead of it so good luck with that
yeah that's appropriate this is all just
to sell this mug that's good luck with
that of a mythical dot store that's what
we were doing if you don't remember
anything remember our newest store if
you would greatly relieve my stress if
you would go and buy one of these mugs
no no no no forget I said that forget I
said I mean I'm sending out love to all
YouTube creators and dedicated fans who
support them you do your thing until you
need to stop for a little bit yeah both
of you don't be ashamed that your
biscuits will speak at you next week
give you an update on what we've found
where is what are we finding our corner
of YouTube that we can enjoy you know
what it's ironic how and I'll save it
for next week not to say some other
pocket you know with we're so invested
in this yet we're like we'll talk about
it next week it's hash tag air biscuits
let us know let's keep the conversation
going
[Music]